(Jack Pop singt „Bella Ciao“)
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier.
Der fünfte Teil von Haus des Geldes ist
draußen und das heißt, wir erfahren endlich wieder
der Einbruch in die spanische Zentralbank ausgeht.
(Auf in die letzte Schlacht mein Dickerchen)
Ich finde die Serie ja vor allen Dingen geil,
weil ich den Professor total feiere.
Weil ich selber totaler Perfektionist
bin und diese ausgeklügelten Pläne, diese
ganze Vorbereitung richtig gut finde.
Die Frage ist aber: Ist er Professor wirklich
so ein Genie? Oder haben seine Pläne vielleicht
doch einen Haken? Das finden wir heute raus,
gemeinsam mit einem Geldschein-Experten von
der EZB und einem Fachmann für Gold. Und
die haben ziemlich überraschende Antworten.
Beginnen wir mal mit Teil eins und Teil
zwei, da will der Professor mit seinem Team
die spanische Banknotendruckerei überfallen.
Und wie genau er sich das jetzt vorstellt,
das fasst uns noch mal jemand zusammen, der Haus
des Geldes wie seine Westentasche kennt, nämlich
Ren vom Kanal Serienflash.
Ja moin Jack! Gerne fasse ich Dir
mal kurz den Plan des Professors zusammen.
Der erste Teil des Plans sieht natürlich
erst einmal vor, eine Crew aus Kriminellen
zusammenzubringen, um diese dann haargenau
zu informieren, was sie denn zu tun haben.
Und der eigentliche Plan sieht dann vor, dass die
Crew in roten Overalls und Dali-Maske sich Zutritt
in die spanische Banknotendruckerei verschaffen,
um dann dort alle Anwesenden als Geisel zu nehmen.
Doch dann räumen sie nicht einfach nur den Tresor
aus. Nein, der Plan ist viel ausgeklügelter. Denn
die Idee ist, selbst Geld zu drucken. Insgesamt
2,4 Milliarden Euro in 50-Euro-Scheinen. Und
das braucht natürlich ein bisschen Zeit. Der
Professor geht von elf Tagen aus und das bedeutet
auch, dass die Crew samt den Geiseln elf Tage in
dem Gebäude verbringen müssen, während die Polizei
draußen wartet und jede Minute eindringen könnte.
Ren, Vielen Dank. Und das klingt doch erst
einmal ganz logisch. Die ganzen Geräte,
also diese Druckmaschinen, die sind ja eh schon
vor Ort vorhanden. Es ist also nur die Frage,
ob die wirklich so viel Geld in so kurzer
Zeit produzieren können. Und das haben wir
mal einen richtigen Geldexperten gefragt,
nämlich Markus Emerich von der Europäischen
Zentralbank in Frankfurt am Main. Der ist
technischer Physiker und leitet bei der
EZB das Forschungs- und Entwicklungsteam für
Banknoten. Und der hat mir erst mal erklärt,
wie so ein Geldschein überhaupt entsteht.
Die Produktion des Geldscheines fängt mit der
Papierproduktion an. Da wird Spezialpapier
erzeugt mit gewissen Sicherheitsmerkmalen
drin und zum Beispiel auch schon die Folie
aufgebracht ist. Diese Hologram-Folie.
Und dieses Papier wird dann zur Druckerei
geliefert. Dort hat die Serie einen großen Fehler.
Und zwar werden dort Rollen geliefert.
Der Euro wird nicht auf Rollen erzeugt,
sondern auf Banknoten-Bögen. Also
größere, geschnittene Papierbögen.
Dann fängt der Druckprozess an. Und da
gibt es mehrere Druckschritte. Wir haben
ein Offsetdruck-Schritt, wir haben
Stahlstich-Tiefdruck, wir haben einen Siebdruck,
wir haben eine Nummerierung.
Also wir haben bis zu fünf
Druckschritte in der Druckerei und was hier
wichtig ist und das ist auch in der Serie
ganz anders, da läuft sozusagen die Produktion
ohne die verschiedenen Druckschritte durch.
Aber in Wirklichkeit muss zwischen den
verschiedenen Schritten die Banknote oder der
der Bogen trocknen, das kann, je nach
Druckschritt, einen Tag, mehrere Tage oder bis
zu einer Woche dauern.
Aber was ganz wichtig ist: Ich
kann nicht in 24 Stunden eine Banknote erzeugen.
Schade, aber das wäre vielleicht auch ein bisschen
zu einfach. Die Frage ist halt: Wie lange braucht
ein Geldschein, bis er jetzt komplett fertig ist?
Also wenn man den ganzen Druckprozess hernimmt
und dann die Trocknung dazwischen, danach geht
es ja erst ins Schneiden. Da wird die Banknote
auf Maschinen geschnitten, und danach gibt es ja
noch einmal eine Qualitätsinspektion.
Und zwar nennt man das „Single Note
Inspection“. Jede einzelne Note wird auf die
Druckqualität und Vollständigkeit überprüft.
Also bis dann der ganze Prozess abgeschlossen
und dann die Banknote verpackt ist,
kann man schon vor vier bis fünf Wochen sprechen.
Also nichts mit elf Tagen, wie der Professor
veranschlagt hat. Über einen Monat hätte er
für die Aktion einplanen müssen und das fand
ich wirklich selbst auch sehr überraschend.
Ich hätte einem Geldschein schon ein paar
Tage für die Produktion gegeben, aber das ist
wirklich ein paar Wochen dauert… Holy Shit!
Und Markus hat mir erzählt, dass dieser Überfall,
so wie er gezeigt wird, eigentlich gar nicht
möglich gewesen wäre. Weil eine Banknotendruckerei
sicherheitsmäßig wie eine Zwiebel aufgebaut ist.
Es gibt also verschiedene Sicherheitsebenen und
jede einzelne davon ist voller Kameras. Da kann
man also nicht so wie dort gezeigt, mal von
der Warenannahme bis zum Drucksaal spazieren.
Aber dann lasst uns jetzt einfach mal
davon ausgehen, dass die das irgendwie
geschafft haben. Die haben dieses Geld
produziert, dann müssen sie es ja am Ende
trotzdem noch aus der Bank abtransportieren.
Dass wäre ehrlich gesagt ganz schöne
Schwerstarbeit, denn ein Schein wiegt zwar nur
ein knappes Gramm, aber für 2,4 Milliarden Euro
bräuchte man 48 Millionen davon.
Und die würden mehr als sieben
ausgewachsene männliche Elefanten wiegen.
Also auch hier braucht es einen ausgeklügelten
Plan. Und da muss noch mal Ren aushelfen.
Was hat sich denn der Professor einfallen
lassen, um diese Massen daraus zu tragen?
Ganz so schwer ist es am Ende für die Crew dann
doch nicht geworden. Denn statt den 2,4 Milliarden
hat man gerade mal 984 Millionen produziert
bekommen. Das Geld wurde dann in kleinen
Päckchen via Geiseln nach draußen transportiert.
Allerdings nicht durch die Vordertür, sondern
durch einen Tunnel. Und zwar ein Tunnel,
der von der Banknotendruckerei zum Versteck des
Professors führte. Und dieser wurde während der
Geiselnahme durch die Geiseln und die Crew
gegraben. Das Geld wurde also durch die
Tunnel transportiert und dann im Versteck in leere
Bierfässer gepackt, auf einen Lkw verfrachtet. Und
der ist dann gemütlich samt Professor abgedampft.
Klingt erstmal ganz easy, aber lasst uns das noch
mal genauer anschauen. Bis die Polizei das
Gebäude stürmt, hat das Team fast die Hälfte
seines Wunschbetrags gedruckt, nämlich 984
Millionen Euro. Die haben die zusammengerollt
Und man erkennt jetzt nicht ganz genau wie viele
Scheine da pro Packung drin sind. Aber Nairobi,
die macht da eine ziemlich klare Ansage dazu.
(So nicht! Wir haben gesagt Rollen zu einer
Million! Also bitte haben wir uns
verstanden. So und nicht anders!)
1 Million Euro in Fünfzigern. Das wäre ordentlich
Gewicht, nämlich etwa 18 kg und damit fast
so viel wie ein voller Kasten Bier. All das
wäre echt superschwierig zu transportieren.
Wenn wir uns die Transportszenen jetzt
ganz genau anschauen, dann sieht man auch,
dass die diese Pakete ja eher so locker
hin und her geben und auch mal eben damit
rumlaufen. Also ich glaube nie im Leben, dass
die sich an Nairobis Anweisungen gehalten haben.
In diesen Paketen muss wesentlich weniger Geld
drin sein als die 1 Million. Deswegen lasst uns
doch jetzt einfach mal vom Standardproduktion
Prozedere in Notendruckereien ausgehen.
Da werden nämlich immer tausend Geldscheine
zu so einem Bündel gemacht. Und dann kommen
zehn von diesen Bündeln in eine Transportbox,
das heißt 10.000 Scheine pro Box. Bei 50ern ist
also eine halbe Million Euro in so einer Kiste,
das wären immer noch neun Kilo. Aber ich glaube,
in so einer Menschenkette ist das
für die Geiseln ganz gut machbar.
Um das ganze Geld jetzt herauszubekommen,
müssen die aber trotzdem 2000 dieser Pakete
von Hand zu Hand geben. In einem
Tunnel, der 486 Meter lang ist,
wie der Professor sagt. Jetzt wissen wir nicht
ganz genau, wie viele Menschen damit anpacken.
39 Geiseln sind zu dem Zeitpunkt maximal noch da,
ein paar von denen müssen woanders eine Explosion
vorbereiten... Also lass uns mal grob mit 40
Menschen rechnen, Geiseln plus Teammitglieder.
Um zu schauen, ob das realistisch ist, also
die Zeit für diese ganze Aktion zu berechnen,
habe ich meinen kleinen Online-Rechner aufgesetzt
und ein bisschen mit den Variablen rumgespielt.
Wir haben also die Tunnellänge von 486
Metern. Wir haben 40 beteiligte Personen
und wir haben 2000 Geldpakete. Wenn wir der
Einfachheit halber jetzt mal davon ausgehen,
dass sich alle beteiligten Personen in dem Tunnel
so gleichmäßig verteilen, dass jede Person für
ihre Geldübergabe den gleichen Weg zurücklegt,
dann können wir auch die Zeit ausrechnen,
die jede dieser einzelnen Geldübergaben braucht.
Dafür müssen wir nur eine Geschwindigkeit
festlegen und die können wir anhand dieser Szene
hier grob abschätzen. Da laufen die noch relativ
entspannt hin und her dafür, dass eigentlich
schon die Polizei vor der Tür steht. Ich würde
sagen das ist so gute Schrittgeschwindigkeit
6km/h und wenn wir diese Werte jetzt nehmen und
das alles durchrechnen, dann kommt raus, dass eine
einzelne Paketübergabe ungefähr 15s Zeit braucht.
Und bei 2000 Paketen kommen wir auf
eine Gesamtzeit von über 8h für die
Aktion. Und das haut mit dem Zeitplan der
Serie überhaupt nicht hin. Denn die Crew
beginnt erst mit dem Abtransport der
Pakete als der Professor schon sieht,
dass das Sondereinsatzkommando bereit ist zu
stürmen. Und selbst wenn der Tunnel nur 100m lang
wäre und die alle ein bisschen schneller laufen,
dann kämen wir immer noch bei einer Stunde raus.
Das sag ich jetzt mit meinem
Rechner. Aber den könnt Ihr nutzen,
um eure eigene Rechnung durchzuführen.
Den Link pack ich in die Infobox.
Und da könnt ihr mal an diesen Schiebereglern
rumspielen. Vielleicht findet Ihr ja eine Lösung,
die viel, viel besser funktionieren würde. Dann
schreibt sie uns doch gerne in die Kommentare.
Aber selbst sie auch das irgendwie
hinkriegen, dann bleibt am Ende trotzdem
noch ein finales Problem, nämlich das alte
Gewichtsproblem. Diese 984 Millionen Euro,
die wollen die mit dem Auto abtransportieren. Die
wiegen aber gut 18t. Und dazu kommt dann noch das
Gewicht von den Bierfässern, vom Professor und
Helsinki, die vorne im Auto sitzen und das,
was wir da in der Szene zu sehen bekommen ist ein
Nissan Atleon. Der hat nur eine Nutzlast von 8t,
also weniger als die Hälfte. Das heißt, die
könnten damit nicht so entspannt vom Hof fahren.
Hier müssen wir also ganz klar sagen,
dass der Plan nicht funktioniert.
Der Plan mit dem Geld drucken würde in der
Realität nicht so gut funktionieren. Aber
vielleicht klappt es ja mit Gold, denn in Teil
drei und vier, das stehen die Goldreserven der
spanischen Zentralbank im Mittelpunkt der Serie.
Und auch dafür gibt es natürlich wieder einen sehr
ausgeklügelten Plan. Den kann uns jetzt noch
mal unser Serienexperte Ren erklären. Ren,
was hat der Professor denn dieses Mal vorbereitet?
Richtig. Diesmal hat es die Crew des Professors
auf die Goldreserven von Spanien abgesehen,
weshalb sie in die Zentralbank in Madrid
einbrechen wollen. Die ist natürlich schwer
beschützt und deswegen initiieren sie erst
einmal ein Ablenkungsmanöver, indem sie 140
Millionen Euro vom Himmel regnen lassen.
Das daraus resultierende Chaos nutzen sie dann
dafür, um unbemerkt in die Zentralbank zu kommen,
wo sie dann natürlich wieder erst
einmal alle als Geisel nehmen,
samt Bankdirektor, der selbst sehr beschützt wird.
Danach versuchen sie natürlich, in den Tresor
zu kommen. Der ist aber Notfall geschützt und
wenn man den einfach so öffnen möchte, wird der
komplette Raum geflutet, weshalb die Crew eine
eigene Schleuse anbringt, die einzelne Personen
eben durch die Tresortür schleust und dann dort im
durchfluteten Tresor die Goldbarren nehmen lässt,
um sie dann nach draußen zu verfrachten. Und vor
der Tür hat man dann ein paar Öfen aufgebaut, um
das Gold direkt in Granulat schmelzen zu lassen,
damit man es einfacher aus der Bank bekommt.
Gut. Gold schmelzen ist prinzipiell kein Problem.
Dafür braucht man nur die richtigen Öfen. Und in
der Serie sehen wir ja, dass die mindestens zwei
von solchen mobilen Schmelzöfen dabeihaben. Samt
Kühlsystem und obendrein noch so eine sehr
komplexe industrielle Entlüftungsanlage.
Falls Ihr Euch gefragt habt, wie die das ganze
Equipment da eigentlich reinbekommen haben,
da gibt es ein ziemlich gutes Video von den
Rocketbeans. Das verlinke ich Euch mal hier oben.
Aber zurück zum Gold schmelzen Nairobi erklärt
in dieser Szene hier dem Bankdirektor das
sie es schaffen, 52 Barren in einer Stunde zu
schmelzen. Lasst uns das mal genauer anschauen.
Ein Goldbarren, der wiegt ungefähr 12,5kg und
insgesamt will das Team mit 90t Gold aus der
Bank rausgehen. Das sind also 7.200 Barren. Dafür
bräuchten sie nach Nairobis Aussage, und wenn die
Öfen wirklich Tag und Nacht durchlaufen,
ungefähr sechs Tage. Ist das realistisch?
Das habe ich mal bei der Scheideanstalt
Berlin nachgefragt. Scheideanstalten,
das sind professionelle Stellen, in denen
Metalle von Verunreinigungen befreit werden
und Metallverbindungen getrennt werden, sodass am
Ende sehr reine Metalle übrigbleiben. Diese werden
dann abgeschieden, daher kommt der Name.
Die kennen sich also mit dem Schmelzen
von Gold bestens aus. Und ich habe mit
Geschäftsführer Robert Erdinc gesprochen,
der sagt prinzipiell geht das.
Wenn Sie ein Kühlungssystem haben,
dann könnten wir auch 24h laufen. Wir haben zum
Beispiel eins, was elektrisch betrieben ist.
Das heißt, der Ofen muss ständig gekühlt werden.
Wenn man das hat, dann kann er auch 24h laufen.
Die Öfen an sich sind also gar nicht der
Knackpunkt. Allerdings brauchen die natürlich
extrem viel Energie, um auf die Schmelztemperatur
von Gold hochzuheizen. Die müssen auf über
1.000ºC kommen. Und da gibt es eine technische
Hürde für den Professor – der Stromanschluss.
Denn allein die Backöfen bei uns
zu Hause im Haushalt, die laufen
ja schon mit Starkstrom. Das heißt, dass man
logischerweise so ein Gold Schmelzofen auch
nicht einfach an eine Steckdose hängen kann.
Es ist unrealistisch, dass da jetzt genau so
eine Starkstromleitung steht. Die müsste man
eigentlich machen. Und in einer Bank braucht
man normalerweise keine Starkstromleitung.
Es heißt, sie müsste eigentlich theoretisch
schon vorher gelegt werden, dass
ist in der Hinsicht unrealistisch.
Okay, kleiner Downer. Aber vielleicht wollen wir
den Professor hier einfach etwas zutrauen. Denn im
ersten Teil hat das ja auch geschafft, ein eigenes
Kommunikationssystem über Kabel in den Toiletten
und der Kanalisation zu verlegen. Also können
wir ihm hier vielleicht auch einfach zutrauen,
dass er die Energieversorgung schon mitgedacht
hat. Und dann könnte das Team mit den richtigen
Öfen und genug Vorbereitung tatsächlich
Goldbarren im Akkord einschmelzen. Und die
müssen nicht mal Angst vor irgendwelchen
giftigen Dämpfen oder vor Rauch haben,
weil Goldbarren so rein sind, dass sie keine
Schadstoffe enthalten. Ein gutes Abluftsystem
braucht der Plan des Professors aber trotzdem.
Es entstehen natürlich extreme Temperaturen.
Ich meine, das ist doch schon
gut dargestellt, weil die Leute
da Unterhemden laufen. Weil es so warm ist.
Aber irgendwann hältst du es in einem Raum,
wo keine Abluft ist, nicht aus. Es wäre
auch unrealistisch, dass man da jetzt
tagelangen einfach durchschmelzen
kann, ohne dass man da umkippt.
Dieses Ventilationssystem was wir da sehen. Das
sieht zwar eher aus wie eine Dunstabzugshaube,
aber könnte natürlich auch dafür genutzt werden,
um die heiße Luft abzuführen und damit den Raum
zu kühlen. Ist der Plan in der Nationalbank also
halbwegs plausibel? Nicht ganz, denn 52 Goldbarren
pro Stunde, das wären 325 Kilogramm Gold pro
Ofen. Und da kommt die Achillesferse der Serie
wieder zum Tragen. Wie schon in Teil eins und Teil
zwei ist einfach die Zeit dafür zu knapp bemessen.
Also das Hochheizen des Ofens dauert erst
mal lange. Aber selbst wenn er jetzt,
sagen wir mal auf Temperatur ist und sie
haben praktisch die erste Schmelze schon
hinter sich und machen sich an die nächste
Schmelzung, dauert es bei der Menge trotzdem
länger als 1h. Realistisch wären vielleicht 2-3h.
Überlegt mal. Das heißt, dass die ganze Aktion
im schlimmsten Fall dreimal so lange dauert wie
angesetzt. Das heißt aber auch im Umkehrschluss,
dass dieser Plan mit der Nationalbank jetzt
nicht so super unrealistisch ist, wenn sich
das Team einfach mit ein bisschen weniger Gold
zufriedengeben würde und ein paar Leute hätte,
die sich gut mit Elektrik auskennen.
Aber auch hier bleibt die Frage: Wie kriegt die
Crew am Ende das Goldgranulat aus der Bank raus.
Teil drei und Teil vier sind uns diese Antwort
bislang schuldig geblieben. Und auch im Trailer
zu Teil fünf gibt es da keinen Hinweis darauf.
Der sieht nach ordentlich rumgeballer aus. Und
ich bin mir sicher, dass es das eine oder andere
Teammitglied wohl leider noch erwischen wird.
Welcher Tote in der Serie hat euch denn am meisten
mitgenommen? Also ich vermisse Oslo sehr. Wie war
es bei Euch? Schreibt es mal in die Kommentare.
Großer Dank geht raus an Ren vom Kanal
Serienflash… für die vielen Flashbacks.
Und auch an Markus Emerich von der
Europäischen Zentralbank und an Robert
Erdinc von der Scheideanstalt für die tollen
und netten Gespräche, die ich dahatte. Links
zu allen pack ich Euch in die Infobox. Und
bevor Ihr Euch jetzt Teil fünf reinzieht,
drückt doch bitte noch auf Abo und
unsere Glocke. Da können wir uns ganz
bald wiedersehen. Ich würde mich sehr
freuen und sage bis dahin „Bella Ciao“.
(Singt „Rotes Gummiboot“)
(Ich war in einer Punk-Band. Da
gab es keine Gesangsausbildung)
(Da gab es einen Kasten Sterni und das war es.)
(Aha).
(Dann stellt man sich ordentlich hin. Da holt
man tief Luft, klopft sich auf die Brust.)
(Lauter Dinge die Du aufnimmst, die
wir nicht am Ende in die Folge packen.)